[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه البدايه من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه التي اتمت عامها الاول مع
الحرب واليوم كانت محله كثيرا من
التصريحات والمواقف بشان هذه الحرب
ومستقبلها هذه الصور الان من فرجينيا
بالولايات المتحده حيث يعقدوا البنتاجون
مؤتمرا صحفيا يتحدث فيه عن الحرب في
اوكرانيا وامدادها بالدعم وكذلك عن
احتماليه تقديم الصين اسلحه الى روسيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
وحصيله عام من الحرب موسكو تؤكد انها لن
تتوقف حتى تحقق اهدافها وتقول ان فرصه
عوده اوكرانيا دوله طبيعيه مرهونه بانهاء
مواصفاته بالاعمال العدائيه
تحضيرات اوكرانيه لشن هجوم مضاد
يتمسك بشعار القتال حتى النصر وفي سياق
الدعم الغربي عقوبات امريكيه جديده على
موسكو ورئيس الوزراء البولندي يسلم دبابات
وعلى وقع اتهامات غربيه لها بالتخطيط
لامداد موسكو بالسلاح بيجين تطرح وثيقه
للحل السياسي في اوكرانيا
يعلن عزمه لقاء نظيره الصيني مصادر لصحيفه
بالحاجه لبدء النظر بمحادثات سلام
في تونس اعتقالات جديده تشمل معارضين
للرئيس سعيد والسلطات توحيد عددا من
الموقوفين الى مكتب مكافحه الارهاب الامم
المتحده تعرب عن قلقها من الاعتقالات
وتدعو الى الحوار وفرنسا تدعو سعيد الى
احترام الحريات وسعيد يقول انه لن يتراجع
عما وصفه بجهود انقاذ الدوله
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم مالات المشهد في
اوكرانيا بعد مرور عام على بدء حرب روسيا
عليها والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي
الخيارات المتوقعه لمستقبل هذه الحرب بعد
مرور عام على اندلاعها خمسه صوت لصالح
امكانيه الدخول في مفاوضات
بينما قال 54% ان الوضع الحالي سيبقى
قائما
اما احد عشر بالمئه فصوتوا لصالح خيار
انسحاب روسيا من اوكرانيا هذا السؤال
سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
عام على بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا قبل عام
بالضبط صدق ما اختلفت الاراء بامكانيه
حدوثه حينها اجتاحت روسيا اوكرانيا حتى
بلغت حدود العاصمه كيف قبل ان تغير موازين
المعارك مساحات السيطره من وقت الى اخر
بعد عام تقول موسكو والحديث لمندوبها في
مجلس الامن الدولي انه لا تراجع عن تحقيق
ما تصفه بعمليتها العسكريه بل وتضيف ان
بامكان الاوكرانيين ان يروا عوده بلادهم
الى ما كانت عليه انهم اوقفوا ما وصفته
باعمالهم العيديه تردكيه بالبنادق وتقول
انه لا حديث قبل الانسحاب الكامل من
اراضيها وتؤكد نيتها تنفيذ هجوم مضاد يقود
للنصر وبين الاثنين مزيد من العقوبات
لموسكو ومزيد من المساعدات العسكريه لك
هذه هي رساله الغرب التي تتهم روسيا بانه
بات الان منخرطا في هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
في تفاصيل ما حدث اليوم قال الرئيس
الاوكراني ان نصر بلاده سيكون امرا محققا
اذا اذا التزم شركاء بلاده بوعودهم واشار
الرئيس الاوكراني الى ان بلاده لن تنتصر
وحدها ولا يمكن ان تقف دوله بمفردها ضد
مثل هذا العدوان وفقت عبيره
وعلى وقع التصعيد واتهامات غربيه لها
بالتخطيط لدعم روسيا بالسلاح اعلنت
الخارجيه والصينيه انها طرحت وثيقه للحل
السياسي تتضمن الوقت الفوري لاطلاق النار
واحترام سياده جميع الدول وحمايه المدنيين
واسرى الحرب
حديث الخارجيه الصينيه تبعه اعلان الرئيس
الاوكراني نيته لقاء نظيره الصيني فيما
نقلت صحيفه نقلت صحيفه
عن مسؤولين ان الرئيس الفرنسي المكرمه
والمستشار الالماني
ابلغ الرئيس الاوكراني انه بحاجه لبدء
النظر بمحادثات سلاما مع روسيا
وفي مقابل الاشارات الدبلوماسيه تستمر
المساعدات العسكريه الغربيه الكلاب حيث
قال رئيس الوزراء البولندي
ماتيوشكي ان بلاده سلمت اوكرانيا اربع
دبابات من طراز
هذا وقد شكلت الاسلحه الغربيه على مدار
عام من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا واحده من
اكثر المسائل اثاره للجدل فقد تخطت قيمه
حزم الدعم العسكري الغربي خمسه واربعين
مليار دولار خلال عام واحد فقط
لم تندثر اثار المعركه في بلده هذه بدايه
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كما لم يختفي
حجم التاثير الذي شكلته الاسلحه المستخدمه
بها من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه التي تصدت
لاليات القوات الروسيه وكبدتها خسائر
كبيره في هذا المكان على اطراف العاصمه
كييف وقعت ما سميت بمجزره الدبابات حيث
اعترضت القوات الاوكرانيه ارتالا من
الاليات الروسيه باستخدام سلاح جافلان
المضاد للدروع اول الاسلحه الغربيه التي
وصلت اوكرانيا
وبعد عام على الحرب يكشف العقيد الكسندر
قائد الكتيبه 72 التي تولت معارك كييف
للجزيره عن اهم اسرار تلك المعارك
كل ما ترونه من اليات مدمره استهدفناها
باسلحه زودنا بها شركاؤنا الغربي
وتدربنا عليهما قبل الحرب
الاسلحه الغربيه المضاده للدروع على
اختلاف انواعها اضافه الى مسيرات
البيرقدار التركيه مكنت الاوكرانيين من
استعاده بلداتهم ودفع القوات الروسيه الى
ما بعد الحدود الشماليه ما شكل نقطه فارقه
في الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا كما يقول لنا
ايجور احد ابرز عربي اتفاقات السلاح مع
الغرب
لم نتسلم الكثير من الاسلحه في الايام
الاولى سوى مضادات الدروع الا ان اثباتنا
القدره على المقاومه وحمايه عاصمتنا شجع
الحلفاء على منحنا اسلحه ثقيله على مراحل
ونتوقع منهم تزويدنا بكل ما نحتاجه من
كافه انواع الاسلحه
باتجاه الجبهات المشتعله شرقا وجنوبا
ارسلت الاسلحه النوعيه لاوكرانيا حيث خصت
جبهات الشرق كباخمت وخاركيف بالمدافع
الامريكيه عاليه الدقه كالحوتزر ومثيلاته
الاوروبيه فيما وجهت نحو الجنوب قذيفات
الصواريخ الحديثه والمضادات الجويه
بعد كان الانسحاب الكبير من مقاطعه
الشرقيه ومدينه خرسون الجنوبيه بعدما تلقت
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك الدعم الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه اللازم المصحوبه بطائرات
الاستطلاع والى الجنوب نتجه للتعرف على
تاثيرها
في طريقنا نرصد وصول مزيد من الدفاعات
الجويه كهذا السلاح الالماني الفعال ضد
الطائرات المسيره وعلى الطريق ذاته عبرت
قاذفات هايس الامريكيه تظهر هذه اللقطات
التي منحنا اياها الجيش الاوكراني لحظه
توجهها نحو الجنوب
اطلاقها رشقات صاروخيه وصل مداها الى 80
كيلو مترا نحو مواقع القوات الروسيه في
خرسون وتدميرها
الى الانسحاب خلفه
وبعدما وصلت نيرانهم الى هنا باتوا
يطالبون بصواريخ يفوق مداها 150 كيلومترا
تمكنها من اصابه شبه جزيره القرم وما فيها
من مواقع ومستودعات استراتيجيه بالاضافه
الى طلب طائرات حربيه على وقع انتظار وصول
الدبابات الغربيه الحديثه
نحو الضفه الاخرى حيث تتمركز القوات
الروسيه جنوبيه خرسون وما بعدها يريد
الاوكرانيون ان تصل صواريخهم والياتهم
التي ينتظرونها من حلفائهم
وللانتصار في هذه الحرب يبدو ان الحاجه
ليست لطول مدى الصواريخ فحسب
للنفس حسن مسعود الجزيره
لان جوله عبر مراسلينا الاستطلاع المزاج
العام في كل العاصمه معنا من كلاب
مراسلتنا كاترين حنا من موسكو ايمن الزبير
من بنتاغون فادي منصور من بيجين ناصر عبد
الحق ومن بروكسيل عبد الله الشامي اهلا
بهم جميعا نبدا بكياب كاترين ما الذي اثار
ربما اهتمام الاوكرانيين اكثر من غيره في
كل ما قيل اليوم
ما قاله الرئيس الاوكراني في سواء في
خطابه الصباحي الذي توجه به الى
الاوكرانيين او في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي
عقده بعد ظهر اليوم وكان مؤتمرا مطولا
تناولت فيه العديد من النقاط الرئيسيه
التي تهم الاوكرانيين والعالم اولا تحدث
عن مساله مفاوضات السلام تحدث عن مساله
التسليح وحاجه اوكرانيا للسلاح وايضا عن
علاقه اوكرانيا بالصين وعن موقف اوكرانيا
من المقترح الصيني للسلام في اوكرانيا
وغيرها من النقاط ابدا بموضوع التسليح
تحديدا حيث اشار الى حاجه اوكرانيا لاسلحه
بعيده المدى اوضح ان هذه الحاجه وهذا
السلاح هو فقط لاستعماله بهدف حمايه
المدنيين حمايه سماء اوكرانيا وحمايه
بنيتها التحتيه واشار الى ان هناك فكره
متداوله من قبل روسيا من الجهات ايضا بان
اوكرانيا تريد الاسلحه بعيده المدى بهدف
استهداف روسيا ولكن روسيا هي من وضعت
اسلحتها في مواقع على مسافه قريبه
لاستهداف المدنيين وقتلهم في اوكرانيا كما
قال ولذلك تريد اوكرانيا فقط ان تستهدف
هذه المواقع بهدف حمايه المدنيين في موضوع
مقترح الصين للسلام هو اشار في هذا الاطار
الى عزمه لقاء نظيره الصيني وقال ان ذلك
سوف يكون مفيدا للبلدين فالقضيه ليس
القضيه حرب فقط بل هناك علاقات اقتصاديه
بين الصين واوكرانيا وهناك تبادل تجاري
كبير بينهما لكنه اوضح ايضا في هذا المجال
نقطه مهمه وهو انه برايه ما طرحته الصين
ليس خطه سلام بل هي افكار وعلينا ان ننتظر
ما سوف يلي هذه الافكار وما الذي سوف تؤدي
اليه مشددا على نقطه مهمه هي مساله وحده
اراضي اوكرانيا وسيادتها وما سماه بالسلام
العادل
عن موسكو ايمن الزبير وهي التي كانت عرضه
اليوم لكل سهام النقد تقريبا
نعم محمد هنا تحديدا لم يكن هناك تقييم
لسير ما تصفه موسكو بالعمليه العسكريه
وانما حديث عن الاهداف التي تصبو الى
تحقيقها نائب مجلس الامن الروسي
قال ان روسيا ستحقق النصر وستبعد كل
التهديدات حتى وان استدعى ذلك التقدم او
الذهاب الى الحدود الاوكرانيه البولنديه
المسؤوله الروسي قال ايضا ان التاريخ يعلم
ان تقدم الجيوش في اشاره الى الجيش الروسي
سيفرض التفاوض على الطرف الاخر وان كان
بهذا التعريف الطرف الاخر يشير الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي تملك
القرار على حد تعبيرها ايضا كانت هناك
اشاره الى المبادره التي قدمتها
قبل حديث الناطقه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
كانت السلطات هنا في روسيا اثنت على الدور
الصيني اليوم
الخارجيه الروسيه تقول انها دائما تؤيد
التسويه السلميه الدبلوماسيه ولكن هناك
مجموعه من الشروط التي يجب مراعاتها اهمها
ربما هي وقف مد كييف بالاسلحه توقف تدفق
من تصفهم بالمقاتلين الاجانب والاعتراف
بالوضع
القائم خاصه بعد ضم العديد من المناطق
الاوكرانيه هذه هي الشروط التي تضعها
موسكو مثل ما اشرت بجين اليوم دخلت على
الخط ناصر عبد الحق هل يمكن فعلا حديث عن
مبادره صينيه
سيدنا محمد لحد هذه اللحظه هي ليست مبادره
بل هي وثيقه او مقترح اقتراحاته الصين
لاحلال السلام ووقف الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وتاتي هذه تتزامن هذه الوثيقه
مع تزايد اتهامات الدول الغربيه
للصين وعلى راسها الولايات المتحده بان
هناك شكوك بان الصين تزود روسيا باسلحه
وذلك ما نفته الصين جمله وتفصيلا وقالت في
مؤتمرات صحفيه لوزاره الخارجيه سابقا بان
على من يزود الحرب بالسلاح ان ينظر الى
نفسه الصين لا تشعل النار ولا تزود اي
دوله ولا تقف مع اي طرف ضد ضد اي طرف اخر
بل تسعى الى احلال السلام ووقف الحرب ايضا
في الوثيقه الصينيه
ركزت الصين على السلاح النووي والمنشات
النوويه سواء في اوكرانيا وقالت بانها خط
احمر ولا ولا يعني لا يجب على اي طرف ان
يستخدم السلاح النووي او يعرض المنشات
النوويه الى الخطر ايضا
ركزت على موضوع المساعدات الانسانيه وضمان
سلاسل التوريد من اوكرانيا وروسيا
وركزت ايضا على العلاقات بين الصين وروسيا
وقالت انها علاقات ثنائيه استراتيجيه ولا
يحق لاي طرف ثالث بالتعرض لهذه العلاقات
نعم محمد في الاثناء واشنطن طبعا فادي
منصور ما زالت عند موقفها الدعم بقوه
لاوكرانيا والتي تنظر بحذر ايضا لهذه
التحركات الصينيه
نعم محمد الولايات المتحده اداره بايدن
اعتبرت انها ذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا هي مناسبه لتجديد
التزام الولايات المتحده بدعم اوكرانيا
على المدى البعيد في بيان لوزيره الدفاع
الامريكي خلال الاعلان عن حزمه المساعدات
الجديده وهي كبيره بقيمه مليارين دولار
وتتضمن اسلحه نوعيه من بينها صواريخ
لراجمات هايمارز من اجل تحويل الصواريخ
الى صواريخ ذكيه وايضا اربعه انواع مختلفه
من الطائرات المسيره والتي بامكانها ان
تستهدف السلاح الثقيله الروسي تحديدا
المدرعات خلال اعلان عن هذه الحزمه قال
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان الرئيس الروسي
بوتين اخطا بالرهان على انهيار الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه واخطا بريهان على تراجع تصميم
الولايات المتحده والعالم على دعم
اوكرانيا وبالتالي هي رساله واضحه من
الجانب الامريكي باستمرار الدعم ولكن ايضا
استمرار الضغوط على روسيا من خلال
الاعلان عن عقوبات مختلفه اليوم هنا في
العاصمه واشنطن فيما يتعلق بالصين كما
اشرت محمد ليس فقط هناك تشكيك من قبل
الولايات المتحده ولكن هناك ايضا تحذير
للصين ترى الاداره الامريكيه انا لو ان
الصين عمليا صادقه في مبادرتها او في
اقتراحاتها فيما يتعلق بالسلام في
اوكرانيا ينبغي ان تحترم مساله سياده
الدول التي تتغنى بها الصين بشكل دائم كما
اشار المتحدث باسم خلال احاطته اليوم هنا
من خلفي في هذا الاطار ورغم قول الاداره
الامريكيه انا ليس لديها اي ادله حتى هذه
اللحظه تشير الى ان الصين عمليا سلمت
روسيا ووفرت لروسيا اسلحه فتاكه للمساهمه
في هذه الحرب لكن الاداره الامريكيه ترى
ان الصين لا تزال تنظر في هذا الخيار ولم
تستبعده بعد بشكل نهائي وهذا ما يفسر
الضغوط المستمره من قبل واشنطن تحذيرها
بيجين من عواقب وخيمه في حال اقدمت على
دعم روسيا محمد نفس تقريبا المزاج في
الموقف الاوروبي عبد الله الشامي بوريل
تحدث عن ان ما قدمته الصين ليس خطه سلام
وفي نفس الوقت الدعم الاوروبي لكياب مستمر
بالفعل محمد الدعم الاوروبي لكييف مستمر
ليس فقط سياسيا وانما اقتصاديا وعسكريا كل
الاصعده يعني يمكن القول ان الاوروبيين
اقدموا على ما لم يقدموا عليه منذ سنوات
طويله ربما منذ انشاء هذا الاتحاد بادئ
الامر الدعم العسكري قيام الاتحاد بدعم
دوله بالسلاح دوله غير عضو فيه كانت هذه
سابقه من نوعها قدم الاتحاد حتى الان 6
مليارات في شكل اسلحه وينتظر او ينتظر
ايضا تقديم 4 مليارات اضافيه لدعمه فيما
تحتاجه من ذخيره واعتاد عسكري في الاسابيع
المقبله ثم بالطبع الموقف السياسي كان
هناك تسريع لعمليه اعطاء صفه المرشح
لاوكرانيا مرشحه للعضويه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي استثناء تم تجاوز بعض الشروط
التي يعني لا بد من المرور بها ثم بين كل
هذا وذاك الاوروبيون يكررون في اكثر من
موق
[موسيقى]
بدات الحرب باعلان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ما وصفها بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه
لتحديد سلاح اوكرانيا وافراغها ممن سماهم
النازيين ومنذ الايام الاولى للحرب ومع
توجه الرجال الى الجبهات تدفق مئات الالاف
من اللاجئين من النساء والاطفال على دول
الجوار في ازمه لاجئين اخرى تضرب اوروبا
على الجبهه اشتد القصف وتسارع تقدم القوات
الروسيه في محاور وتباطا في اخرى لكن
انسحابها من بلده بوشا شمال كيف كشف عن
عشرات المقابر الجماعيه وسط تمديد دول
غربيه بما وصفتها الوحشيه الروسيه في مايو
تركزت الانظار على مصنع الحديد في
ماريوبول حيث استمعت المقاتلون
الاوكرانيون في الدفاع عنه تحتوي من القصف
الروسي لكنها مقاومه انتهت بالاستسلام
[موسيقى]
حبس مفاعلها النووي انفاس العالم اكثر من
مره وتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات بالمسؤوليه
عن قصف محيط المفاعل الاكبر في اوروبا
والذي يهدد اي تسرب نووي فيه القاره
باسرها في وقت تستمر فيه الدعوات لافراغ
محيطه من المقاتلين اخبار سعيده بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين حملها شهر سبتمبر حيث انسحبت
القوات الروسيه من خاركيف بعد معارك طاحنه
في نصر كان الاوكرانيون في امس الحاجه
اليه انسحاب دفع وزير الدفاع الروسي الى
اعلان التعبئه الجزئيه واستدعاء مئات
الالاف من الجنود في ظل زخم تدريجي بدات
القوات الاوكرانيه في اكتسابه
عصر
الشمرود روسيا باعلانها ضم مناطق يونيون
تحت سيادتها بعد اجراء استفتاءات شككت في
مصداقيتها اوكرانيا ومعها الدول الغربيه
في الثامنه من اكتوبر استيقظ العالم على
تفجير جسر القرن الرابط بين الاراضي
الروسيه وشبه الجزيره التي ضمتها روسيا
عام 2014 في ضربه كانت موجعه التفجير اغضب
الروسي وردت عليه موسكو بعد يومين بحمله
قصف مكثف استهدفت محطات الكهرباء في
العاصمه كييف غرقت بعدها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه في الظلام لاسابيع واقع لم ينل
من معنويات القوات الاوكرانيه التي نجحت
في تحقيق تقدم في مدينه خرسون انتهى
باستعاده السيطره على المدينه في الثاني
عشر من نوفمبر في الاشهر التاليه ومع
الشداد البرد وتاثير الصقيع على سير
المعارك دخلت الحرب مرحله لم يستطع فيها
اي طرف تحقيق اختراق ويقول مراقبون انه
واقع لن يستمر طويلا مع استمرار تجهيز
الروس لهجوم في الربيع واستعداد اوكراني
مسنود باسلحه نوعيه قادمه من الغرب
الان الى جولتنا التحليليه ينضم الينا من
موسكو الكسندر غورنوف الاستاذ في معهد
موسكو للصحافه الدوليه من كياف الدكتور
ايضا اس كبير الباحثين في المعهد
الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن
ميريلاند تشارلز عضو مجلس الامن القوميه
الامريكيه السابق اهلا بهم جميعا نبدا من
موسكو
السيد
الكل اليوم يتحدث عن بوتين عن انه هو
المسؤول عن اندلاع هذه الحرب وهو الذي
بامكانه ان يوقفها كيف نظر الى ذلك في
موسكو
يتم اعتباره الامر كالتالي ساشرح لكم
بدايه قد تتذكر ان الصراع العسكريه في
اوكرانيا قد بدا في عام 2014 مباشره بعد
الانقلاب
والذي تمويله من قبل الولايات المتحده
روسيا كانت امر خريطه في هذا الصراع
العسكري محاوله ان تنهيه تتذكرون ما يسمى
اتفاق منسك الذي تم تمويله ودعمه من قبل
روسيا وفرنسا والمانيا وايضا بين كياف
وبين الجمهوريات المنفصله
رئيس بوتين كان ان يقنع حاول ان يقنع بان
يوافقوا على شروط اتفاق ماسك خلال ذلك
الاتفاق تم ذكر ان منطقه دونيس كتبقى جزءا
من اوكرانيا ستحصل على نوع من
الحقوق الاستقلاليه لكنها بشكل اساسي
لديها الحق في ان تكون اللغه الروسيه هي
اللغه الام لان المنطقه يذكرها الروس
باغلبيه بالتالي الرئيس بوتين حاول ان
يوقف هذا الحرب لكنه لم يكن ناجحا ولم
يحصل هذا الامر بالتالي روسيا قررت انها
تضع اطارا
للولايات المتحده وتضع تاريخا محددا
للولايات المتحده لان الولايات المتحده
كانت تدخل كثير من الاسلحه
بالقربي من الحدود الروسيه الرئيس
ولكن في المقابل اسمح لي اسمح لي
بالمقاطعه السيد في المقابل اسمح لي
سانتقل الى الى كيف حتى نكون عادلين يعني
بين بين روسيا وبين اوكرانيا ايضا
الرئيس الاوكراني سيد
ايفان الرئيس الاو بدا مقتنعا
ومؤمنا بالانتصار اذا اوفى الغرب بوعوده
هل يمكن ان يحصل ذلك
سلام عليكم السلام عليكم
من المكان الذي في عام
2004 عشر
قاتل الكثير وهذا دعا الى بدايه الحرب كما
ذكر
صناديق زميلي في موسكو وتحياتي الى الضيف
الاخر اعتقد ان رئيس وحده هو يؤمن بالناصر
نحن هنا في اوكرانيا نعتقد ان النصر ممكن
وبدعم شركائنا الذين
كانت مساعدتهم اكثر جديه لاننا دعونا
صريحين قبل سنه كانت روسيا اقرب الى تحقيق
النصر وما هي عليه الان بالتالي الوقت هو
ليس في صالح روسيا بالتالي نحن نرى ونفهم
ان روسيا تواجه ليس فقط
المشاكل العسكريه والصعوبات العسكريه لكن
مشاكل اقتصاديه ايضا ان جنود يتلقوا
رواتبهم ومن يدعم الحرب هنا دفع الحرب في
روسيا الاشخاص هناك الكثير منهم من الجنود
هم لا يتلقوا رواتبهم الكثير من الاشخاص
لا تم معاقبتهم ايضا بفرع عقوبات عليهم
بالتالي عندما نرى الصوره باكملها نحن
متاكدون ان اوكرانيا باستطاعتها ان تحقق
النصر في هذه الحرب واوكرانيا سوف تنتصر
الشرط ان يستمر الدعم الغربي الذي نسال
عنه السيد
هل هذا الاستمرار مضمون الى غايه متى
لحد الان الحرب
عم صارت على لمصلحه اوكرانيا كما قال
الضيف في كيف حاول
النظام كيف ولم تنجح وبعد ذلك استطاعتك
اوكرانيا استعاده حواليها نصف الاراضي
التي استولت عليه روسيا في شهر فبراير
الان حاليا الصوره هي ان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها
سيواصلون التقديم الدعم العسكري
والاقتصادي لاوكرانيا ولابد من القول ان
عزيمه وثبات التحالف عبر الاطلسي كان يثير
للاعجاب ما هو محتمل ان نراه نتطور في
الاشهر القادمه امر لا يعرفه اي شخص ان كل
من روسيا واوكرانيا اوكرانيا
هجمات عسكريه وكما قال الرئيس بايدن ذا
اكثر من مره هو مستعد لدعم اوكرانيا
استغرق ذلك هل هل اعتقد ان الامر سينتهي
بنصر كامل لاوكرانيا وطرد كامل قوات روسيه
من الاراضي اوكرانيا من يعلم ربما لا ولكن
من الواضح ان اوكرانيا في وضع يدعو الى
القول بانها تحقق تقدم وقدر ما بعد ذلك
سنصل لمساله الركود عسكريه ياتي بعدها
الجهود او الحلول الدبلوماسيه ولكن الوضع
بالنسبه لموسكو سيد جورنوف لا يبدو مريحا
ما تفضلت بذكره قبل قليل وما تكرره موسكو
باستمرار يبدو غير مقنع للمجتمع الدولي هل
ستستمر موسكو في نفس هذا الخطاب
بالتاكيد ستستمر في هذا الامر والامر وقد
يتطلب الامر بعض الوقت وربما
توصلنا الى هذا الاستنتاج من خلال خطاب
الرئيس بوتين الاخير ينتهي غدا قد يتطلب
وقتا اضافيا ربما سنوات لكن موسكو ستحقق
اهداف اريد ان احيي الولايات المتحده قالت
الولايات المتحده ان هذه الحرب ستكون
لصالح اوكرانيا هذا هذه الحرب تعطي الكثير
من الفائده للولايات المتحده اما بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا ذكر زميلي ان روسيا تواجه
صعوبات اقتصاديه نعم روسيا تواجه اقتصاد
صعوبات اقتصاديه لكن اقتصادها يزداد قوه
وما زال منتعشا لكن اوكرانيا بالمقابل ليس
لها اي اقتصاد على الاطلاق اوكرانيا اليوم
دوله فاشله تعيش فقط وتعتمد بشكل على
التبرعات الامريكيه امريكا
جنه الكثير من الاموال وحدت 50 بلدا ضد
روسيا لكن 100 بلد اخر هناك وهنالك تعبير
خاص يسمى اغلبيه العالم اغلبيه العالم هو
ليس خلف الولايات المتحده لكن اغلبيه
العالم ينتظر واذا ما نجحت روسيا في
مواجهه هذه هذا الطغيان
الامريكي فان العالم سيكون عالما مختلفا
عما كان عليه في السابق سيكون عالما متعدد
الاطراف متعدد القوه ولا تسيطر عليه دوله
عدائيه واحده متمثله بالولايات المتحده
يشاطرك نفس الكلام خاصه الحديث عن ان
اوكرانيا دوله فاشله الان وتعتمد بالكامل
على الغرب
في حقيقه الامر فقط رقم خلال السنه
الماضيه اوكرانيا نعم
واجهتها مشكلات اقتصاديه خطيره بسبب
الاحتلال الروسي لكن بعد ادراك وبعد
استئناف مبادره البحر الاسود فان
صادرات الحبوب من اوكرانيا كانت تساوي
مليار دولار في الشهر وهذه احدى القياسات
المهمه في اقتصاديات صادرات اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي خلال السنوات الماضيه
مقارنه بالسنه في عام 2021 قد زادت بنسبه
4.4% بمعنى انه مع وجود كل المشاكل في
الاقتصاد لكن الاقتصاد ما زال موجودا
وناشطا وحتى اننا باستطاعتنا ان نزيد بعض
الصادرات
والصادرات المتمثله بالح وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بمبادره الحبوب من البحر الاسود مع تعاون
مع تركيا بل لعبت دورا المهمه لقد تلقينا
مليار دولار في الشهر من الحبوب
شكرا لك سيدي
كيف شكرا لالكسن من موسكو شكرا
على اوكرانيا ما يشبه سباقه تسلح حيث تخلى
الدول عن سياسه الحياد التي التزمتها
لعقود بينما عدلت اخرى دساترها بما يسمح
لها بصياغه سياسه دفاعيه جديده
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا لم يعد العالم عقب
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير 2022 كما كان
قبله اجبرت دول على اعتناق عقيده عسكريه
جديده وانقلبت اخرى على مبادئ تاريخيه
فغيرت الدساترها تتخلص السويد وفنلندا عن
رفاهيه حياد استمر قرنين من الزمان الى حث
الخطى نحو عضويه النيتو خطوه ترافقت مع
قرارات لتغيير العقيده العسكريه للبلدين
الجارين لروسيا وفق خطتها العسكريه فان
السويد سترفع انفاقها العسكري بنحو 40%
بحلول عام 2026 وفي خطوه تاريخيه عززت
السويد وجودها العسكري في جزيره غوتلاند
الواقعه في بحر البلطيق على بعد 330
كيلومترا فقط من كالينينغراد مقر اسطول
البلطيق الروسي تشترك فنلندا في حدود بريه
شاسعه مع روسيا ترى هيل سينكي نفسها مطمعا
محتملا
فراحت تستثمر في قدراتها الدفاعيه اذ
تقدمت بطلب لشراء 64 مقاتله اف 35 بقيمه
تسعه مليارات ونصف المليار دولار ووضعت
هيلسنكي خططا لحشد قوات احتياط قوامها 280
الف جنديا مدرب وهو ما لا يمكن لاي دوله
اخرى في اوروبا القيام به
وحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا كانت طلقه
تحذيريه دفعت الغرب لفتح خزائنه لاعلى
انفاق عسكري منذ الحرب البارده فشهدنا
عوده الكبار امثال المانيا التي قررت
التخلي عن مبادئ تاريخيه في ظل الاعتماد
الطويل الامد على الوجود العسكري الامريكي
اعتمدت برلين تغييرات جذريه في سياستها
الامنيه والدفاعيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بامداداتها العسكريه للجيش
الاوكراني وهو تحول كبير في سياسه المانيا
الرافضه لتزويد مناطق الصراع بالاسلحه لكن
التحول الاكبر في برلين كان رفع الانفاق
العسكري لاكثر من 100 مليار دولار لتحديث
الجيش الالماني
اليابان ايضا احد اللاعبين الكبار
العائدين غيرت اليابان عقيدتها العسكريه
جذريا مفصيحه عن استراتيجيه الامن القومي
الجديده لمواجهه ما سمتها بيئه عدائيه من
روسيا والصين وكوريا الشماليه وعليه اعاده
طوكيو بناء قواتها المسلحه بما يسمح لها
بشن هجوم مضاد على اي طرف يعتدي عليها او
على حلفائها وطلبت في سبيل ذلك صواريخ
كروز يصل مداها الى 1600 كيلو متر كما
تعاقدت على شراء طائرات اف 35 الامريكيه
كما وتبقي اليابان على بنيه تحتيه قادره
على بناء اسلحه نوويه في اي وقت تشاء
بامتلاكها مخزونا كبيرا من البلوتونيوم
يكفي لصنع سته الاف قنبله ذريه في المقابل
تتبنى روسيا عقليه توسعيه في دول سوفيتيه
سابقه فضمت مناطق في شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا
مثل دونيات
ومن قبلها القرم يحذر الغرب من حرب جديده
تخطط لها روسيا في مولدوفا عبر نفوذ بدات
تنسج خيوطه في اقليم ترانسنستيريا حيث
1500 جندي روسي وعلى شواطئ البحر الاسود
لروسيا قدم ثانيه في ابخازا الجنوبيه
اللتين اعلنتان في صالهما عن جورجيا بدعم
من موسكو
تثير حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا رياح خوف
تعصف بمضيق تايوان حيث تخشى الجزيره
المستقله عن الصين من ان يتكرر فيها مجاره
في اوكرانيا قبل عام
وكذلك قرار بجين التاريخي برفع ميزانياتها
العسكريه الى 230 مليار دولار وهي ثاني
اكبر ميزانيه دفاعيه في العالم ردت برصد
نحو 19 مليار دولار للانفاق الدفاعي العام
المقبل تشمل تمويلا لطائرات مقاتله جديده
عام واحد من حرب اوكرانيا كان كافيا لان
يدخل العالم في سباق تسلح فهل ينقلب
السباق لمواجهه عسكريه ام هو مسار فرضته
الظروف على دول ادركت ان حيادها لن يقيها
نيران الحرب
معنا الان في الاستوديو الدكتور لقاء مكه
الباحث الاول في المركز مركز الجزيره
للدراسات ومن وارسو الدكتور عمر عاشور
والساده الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
والذي نبدا معه اولا لنساله عن ابرز ما
سجل ضمن التغييرات السياسيه
والجيوستراتيجيه التي اشرنا اليها الان في
التقرير
ابرزنا سجل ربما
الانفاق الاعلى
كان يضع الاثنين في المئه من الناتج
المحلي للانفاق العسكري منذ 2006 الان
يوجد بعض الدول تجاوزته وانا هنا في
بولندا وهي تجاوزته لاكثر من اثنين.4% من
الانفاق العسكري هناك ايضا المام بالعوده
الى
كل ما يخص
العسكريه التقليديه بمعنى سواقه على
المدرعات قضايا في المدفعيه
القدره التعبئه والحشد قدره على تدريب
وتجهيز الاحتياط قوه الاحتياط لها دور
كبير في اوكرانيا وبالتالي ما يعني
تجاوزنا موضوع الاعتماد على الحروب
السيبرانيه وحروب الاستخبارات عن الحروب
الهجينه للعوده الى ما يمكن ان يكون ان
نسميه الحكمه الصناعيه للحرب التي كان ظن
العالم انه تجاوز بعد واربعين كما ان هناك
خشيه حقيقه في الدوله الصغيره تحديدا من
ان في حاله نجاح روسيا في في اوكرانيا
لن يكون لن يكون هناك
رابع واضح يرضى الدول الكبرى من التعدي
واقتطاع اجزاء من الدول اصغر منها
وبالتالي
التركيز هنا على يعني تقريبا
اكثر منه محاوله للردع
ارسال
اشاره للخصم ان الدوله المستهدفه جاهزه
لديها جيشها لديها مدرعاتها لديها
احتياطها لديها مدفعياتها لديها قوه
الجويه
هذا على الصعيد العسكري والاستراتيجي ماذا
عن الصعيد السياسي الدكتور لقاء مكه يبدو
وكان
المعادله الدوليه
اهتزت خلال هذا العام
تغير بشكل يبدو انه نهائي بعد حرب
اوكرانيا حتى اللحظه ومن الواضح جدا ان
النظام القطب الواحد على الاقل من ناحيه
اذا اعتبرنا الغرب كله قطب واحد ما زال
مهيمنا عمليه التعدديه القطبيه التي
تريدها الصين روسيا لم تصل الى نتائج
حاسمه حتى اللحظه لكن لم ينتهي الامر الان
روسيا في حاله هزيمه هي لم تهزم لكنها
الان في حاله هزيمه كيف لانه جرت الى حرب
لم تخطط لها ولم تكن تريدها بهذه الحده هي
كانت تتوقع عن الامر اسهل من ذلك بكثير
لاستنزاف الذي يجري لروسيا كبير جدا تم
عزلها عن العالم بشكل واضح
بتصويتين في الامام المتحده ضدها رغم ذلك
رغم انه في دول امريكا في افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه ما زالت تقف مع روسيا او على
الاقل على الحياد الصين ما زالت تقف مع
روسيا او على الاقل على الحياه حتى اللحظه
لكن في النهايه روسيا في حاله عزله
علاقتها باوروبا انتهت لفتره طويله مقبله
هي لم تحقق اهدافها الحقيقيه في اوكرانيا
هي الان في حاله هزيمه عسكريا لكن من
الناحيه الاستراتيجيه حتى الان لم تحسم
الامور ما زالت الحرب ويبدو ان حرب ستكون
طويله ومكلفه للجميع الاطراف حتى الغرب
بما فيه الغرب الغرب الذي هيمن على العالم
منذ الحرب الصناعيه ما زال كذلك ويريد ان
يجعل من حرب اوكرانيا
تسبب في بقاء مهيمن على المحيط والمجال
العالمي ربما للقرن الحالي هذه المره دخلت
الصين على الخط اقصد هذه المره يعني اليوم
بالحديث عن امكانيه ان تكون لديها مبادره
او على الاقل تصور عام لامكانيه الحل هل
تعتقد بان الصين يمكن ان تلعب تدور في ظل
هذا الاستقطاب الحاد بين الغرب وبين روسيا
هذا هذه المبادره متغير شديد الاهميه رغم
انه الناتو والامريكان وطبعا زيلينسكي
يعني ابدوا عدم قناعتهم بها لا يقول رفض
صريح ولكن عدم قناعه لكن هي نعتقد خطوه
مهمه للغايه في طريق مقاربه صينيه جديده
في التعامل مع الموضوع الاوكراني هذه
الحرب خطيره للغايه والصين تستشعر الخطر
هي لا تريد من ناحيه ان تفرط بالروسيا من
ناحيه الثانيه لا تريد للقرب ان ينتصر ليس
فقط ان تنتصر روسيا لكن لا يريد الغرب ان
ينتصر لانه هي ستكون التاليه على هذا
الاساس هذه المقاربه ستخبئ اهميتها ليس
فيها لانها لن تمشي يعني لن تنجح اهميته
فيما سيجري خلفها الخطوه الصينيه التاليه
التي تريد بكين ان تقوم بها بعد هذه
الخطوه هذا هذا الصين السياسيه الصين
العسكريه دكتور عمر عاشور يجري حديث من
حين الى اخر بامكانيه دخولها على الخط
كمزود
لروسيا هل يمكن ان تقطع هذه الخطوه مع ما
يمكن ان تتحمله من تكلفه
يمكن هو لا احد يريد ان يكون مع الجانب
الخاسر يعني يمكن لكن حتى الان
يكون هناك اي تزويد بسلاح فتاك من قبل
الصين لروسيا في خلال المؤتمر مينيخ
الاخير
وبالتالي حتى الان غير واضح انهم يريدون
ان يتخذوا هذا لكن يوجد تزويد بما هو
الموارد التي يمكن تستخدم مدنيا وعسكريا
كذلك يوجد تزويد ببعض هذه المواد
ايضا ببعض المعدات الحمايه
الشخصيه فيوجد من هذا لكن بشكل عام
الصين يعني
غير لم تتبنى عسكريا
روسيا حتى الان انا فقط اريد ان اعود
سمحتي سريعا على موضوع الناتج المحلي هذا
لانه الانفاق الذي خسرته اوكرانيا في
الفتره السابقه
هذه الاثني عشر شهر الاخير
يعادل في بعض التقديرات 20% عشرين سنه من
الناتج المحلي الاوكراني يعني الدوله خسرت
الكثير وبالتالي الانفاق 2% واكثر هذا
للردع بالاساس اظن انه سيكون يعني الكثير
سيقتنعون به ولو كانوا غير مقتنعين به من
قبل شكرا لك دكتور عمر عاشور من وارسول
شكرا لك دكتور لقامك على حضورك معنا هنا
في الاستوديو
لن اعود الى الملف الاوكراني بعد دقائق في
فقره في المتابعه وذلك للحديث عن كيف
انقلب ميزان المعارك على الارض خلال عام
من هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
في تونس قالت جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه
المعارضه ان النيابه العامه احاله
القياديين في الجبهه في الجبهه جوهر بن
مبارك وشيماء بن عيسى والامين العام للحزب
الجمهوري عصام الشابي والنشاط السياسي
خياب التركي والناشط عبد الحميد الجلاصي
حالتهم جميعا الى مكتب التحقيق بالمجمع
القضائيه لمكافحه الارهاب هذا وقد اعرب
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ستيفان عن قلق المنظمه الدوليه ازاء
التطورات الاخيره في تونس واصفا حمله
الاعتقالات بالتعسفيه كما اعربت الخارجيه
الفرنسيه ايضا عن قلقها من التطورات
الاخيره في تونس
يتارجح الشارع التونسي في خضم تعقيدات
مختلفه مع استمرار السيال بين الرئيس قيس
سعيد ومعارضيه يوما بعد اخر ينتقل الوضع
من تعقيد لاخر مع تاكيد السعيد مضيه قدما
فيما وصفه بانقاذ الدوله وبانه لن يتراجع
ابدا في المقابل يتنامى التحرك المعارض
على خلفيه حمله اعتقالات
واستدعاءات تشتد
نغيب الصحفيين واحد ممن يواجهون التهم من
قبل الدوله وصف ما يجري بانه محرقه ضد
حريه الراي اما رئيس جبهه الخلاص احمد
نجيب الشابي الذي مات معظم شركائه في
القياده معتقلين قال ان الحمله اصبحت تعم
كل الاوصاد ولا تستثني احدا وهو حديث
لاحقه اعتقال قيادين اخر في جبهته جوهر
مبارك والتهمه التامر على الدوله
حركه النهضه التي يستمر استدعاء زعيمها
راشد الغنوشي للتحقيقات قالت انما يجري هو
ملاحقه لرموز المعارضه والناشطين بتهم
وصفتها بانها مزيفه وملفقه ودعت القضاء
الى عدم الانصياع لضغوط السلطه واطلاق
سراح موقوفين بينما استنكر الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل ما قال انه ابعاد للقظام
مناصبهم وتهديد لامنهم وحياتهم ويرفض
الاتحاد كل محاولات الزيج بالنقابيين في
السجون
القضاء فيها تحت الهرسله القضاء فيها
يستعمل ويهدد واذا ما يمشيش
احنا مع قضاء مستقله وهنا يحضر ملف القضاء
حيث برزت مجددا قضيه القاضي المعزول
البشير العكرمي بعد ان حذر محاميه من
امكانيه اخراج موكله بالقوه واختطافه بعد
محاصره قوى الامن لمستشفى الامراض النفسيه
والعقليه الذي يعالج فيه مخاوف عززها
العكرمي بتسجيل من داخل المستشفى
بعد العلاج بدم سبع ايام
[موسيقى]
المستمره ولكن
منظمه العفو الدوليه ان حمله الاعتقالات
تنفذ لاعتبارات سياسيه وانها محاوله
متعمده للتضييق على منتقد الرئيس سعيد
وسياساته بينما وصفت منظمه هيومن رايتس
الاعتقالات بانها محمله برساله من الرئيس
تغلق باب الانتقاد والمعارضه
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده الى اوكرانيا فبين فبراير شباط
عام 2022 ويومنا هذا كان مشهد المعارك على
الارض متقلبا هذا ما كان تبدو عليه
الخريطه فجر الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
شباط عام
2022 حيث استيقظ الاوكرانيون يومها اعلم
انفجارات قويه هزت كيف تزامن معها توغل
عسكري روسي بعد اسابيع ثبتت القوات
الروسيه اقدامها جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا لكن
خطتها بشان كيف التي حاصرتها لم تتم ويقول
الجيش الاوكراني انه نجح في افشال مسعى
الروس للدخول العاصمه لكن بلغت مساحه ما
سيطرت عليه روسيا حينها سبعه وعشرين
بالمئه من مجمل اراضي اوكرانيا في سبتمبر
ايلول الماضي شن الجيش الاوكراني هجوما
مضادا في خركب شمال شرقي البلاد ما ادى
لتراجع القوات الروسيه كما استطاع الجيش
الاوكر دخول مدينه خرسون وعلى مدى الاشهر
التاليه تركزت المعارك في دونتسك حيث
سيطرت القوات الروسيه على مدينه على مدينه
سوليدار وتحاول السيطره على كامل مدينه
بخموت اليوم الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحرب
تبدو خريطه اوكرانيا هكذا انخفضت نسبه ما
تسيطر عليه القوات الروسيه الى نحو سبعه
عشر بالمئه لكن الجبهات بالكاد تتغير ولا
مفاوضات ولا انتصار حاسما لاحد حتى حتى
هذه اللحظه قد يكون من الصعب فهم حجم
تاثير هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا لكن الارقام
تكشف هول الامر كم عدد الاشخاص الذين
تاثروا بهذه الحرب اللاجئون تجاوز عددهم
ثمانيه ملايين شخص اكثر من خمسه ملايين
منهم لجاوا الى اربعين دوله في اوروبا
واسيا الوسطى وحوالي ثلاثه ملايين الى
روسيا
بالنسبه للنازحين بلغ عددهم خمسه ملايين
واربعمائه الف شخص نزحوا من بيوتهم لاحقا
عاد اكثر من خمسه ملايين الف الى ديارهم
وفقا للمنظمه الدوليه للهجره اقتصاديا
بلغت قيمه الاضرار التي لحقت بالبنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه حواليه 63 مليار دولار
ينضم الينا الان من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد الدويري الان امام هذه
الخسائر التي كنا نشير اليها هل تعتقد بان
العام المقبل قد يكون اسوا
يعني الان المعارك مستمره
والترقب يدور حول هجوم الربيع كلا
الجانبين يتحدث عن بناء واعداد القوه
لتنفيذ هجوم الربيع الان هل سيكون هجوم
متقابل في نقاط محدده
ومختلف في مناطق اخرى من صاحب المبادئه من
صاحب اليد العليا الان هذا يعتمد على قدره
جانبي الصراع على بناء القوه في الجانب
الروسي
لديه المعدات لديه مخزونات ذخيره معقوله
حتى هذه اللحظه في الجانب الاوكراني لديه
وعود
بارسال متطلبات المعركه الهجوميه لكن حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يصل الكثير منها يعني عندما
تتحدث
بعض الدول عن ارسال اربع دبابات او
دبابتين او غير ذلك هذه الارقام لا تعدل
لا تجري اي تعديل على مستوى الصراع
وتطورات الصراع اذا دعني اقول الوعود سخيه
الذي يصل على ارض الواقع محدود هل سيتم
ايصال كافه المعدات الى اوكرانيا اذا حدث
ذلك سيدوق كون لديها القدره على شن هجوم
وشنع عمليات تعرضيه في مناطق محدده لكن
دعني اقول بناء على موازين او القدره
القتاليه لطرفي الصراع وموازين القوه لا
يوجد حتى في هجوم الربيع من يملك اوراق
القوه التي تمكنه من تحقيق الانتصار
المعنى ذلك العمليات العسكريه يعني عفوا
هل معنى ذلك بان لا روسيا قادره على
اوكرانيا ولا اوكرانيا قادره على ان تهزم
روسيا هذا سيستمر حتى في العام الثاني
يا سيدي يعني بناء على المعطيات الحاليه
وبناء على ما يصل من معدات اقول لا روسيا
قادره على تحقيق الاهداف التي وضعها وضعها
وهذا خارج اطار قدرات العسكريه لانه هناك
التحالف الغربي يقف خلف اوكرانيا وهو الذي
ثبتها ولكن الامدادات الغربيه لا تمكن
واؤكد لا تمكن اوكرانيا من استعاده ما
فقدته حتى في حال استثناء شبه جزيره القرم
هذا يعني ان عام 2030 الف 2023 الحالي قد
لا يشهد تحقيق الانتصار وقد تدخل الحرب في
عام 2024 المعنى ذلك اننا قدنا نصل الى
تسويه اذا تعب الطرفان وانهك تماما
هذا ما يجري الرهان عليه وهذا المبادره
الصينيه
والحديث ما بين المستشار الالماني والرئيس
الفرنسي بان كان هناك تواصل مع الرئيس
الاوكراني ان يفكر جديا بمسح السلام لانه
هذه الحرب حتى هذه اللحظه نقول المعادله
خاسر خاسر
لاوكرانيا حققت انجازات لتستعيد ارضها ولا
روسيا حققت انجازات التي من اجلها سنه
الحرب اذا دعني اقول لا يزال القتال خاسر
خاسر لكن ماذا سيجري في هجوم الربيع هذا
يعتمد على قدره روسيا على حشد قوه اضافيه
وقدره الغرب على ايصال المعدات التي وعدت
بها اوكرانيا شكرا اللواء فايز الدويري
كنت معنا من عمان
مستمرون معكم نلقاكم باذن الله على راس
السنه
والعالم بعد عام على الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا الا تحمل زياره الرئيس الامريكي
وخطاب الرئيس الروسي اخبارا سيئه للبشريه
ام ان روسيا ماضيه في خطتها رغم ضغوط
الغربيه اليس من الخطا التبشير بهزيمه
موسكو الاتجاه المعاكس الثلاثاء في 10:05
مساء بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
الحكم حدوده يراقبه المشرع يحاسبه القضاء
ويكشفه الاعلام وعندما تخفق كل هذه
السلطات لابد من سلطه فوقها انتم فوق
السلطه يعاد السبت في السادسه والنصف
صباحا بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
نحلل معطيات الحاضر
ننقل الاخبار الاليه
لنرصد كل ما يدور في فلك الاعلام
والاعلاميين
[موسيقى]
المرصد الاثنين في السابعه والنصف مساء
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
يعني اينما وضعت الكاميرا دائما انت محط
اتهامي
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا وحصيله عام من الحرب واسكت واكد
انها لن تتوقف حتى تحقق اهدافها وتقول ان
فرصه عوده اوكرانيا دوله طبيعيه مرهونه
بانهاء مواصفاته بالاعمال العدائيه
تحضيرات اوكرانيه لشن هجوم مضاد
يتمسك بشعار القتال حتى النصر وفي سياق
الدعم الغربي عقوبات امريكيه جديده على
موسكو ورئيس الوزراء البولندي يسلم دبابات
وعلى واقع اتهامات غربيه لها بالتخطيط
لامداد موسكو بالسلاح بيجين تطرح وثيقه
للحل السياسي في اوكرانيا
تصفها بالمساهمه المهمه
لقاء نظيره الصيني مصادر لصحيفه
لبدء النظر بمحادثات سلام
في تونس اعتقالات جديده تشمل معارضين
للرئيس السعيد والسلطات توحيد عددا من
الموقوفين الى مكتب مكافحه الارهاب الامم
المتحده تعرب عن قلقها من الاعتقالات
وتدعو الى الحوار وفرنسا تدعو سعيد الى
احترام الحريات وسعيد يقول انه لن يتراجع
عما وصفه بجهود انقاذ الدوله
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله في الذكرى
السنويه الاولى لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان النصر سيكون امرا
محققا اذا التزم شركاء بلاده بوعودهم كما
اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني عزمه لقاء نظيره
الصيني وفي تصريح روسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي الذي عقد جلسه خاصه بمناسبه مرور
عام على الحرب قل المندوب الروسي
غسيليا ان بلاده مستعده للتفاوض بشان
كيفيه تنفيذ اهداف عمليتها العسكريه
باستخدام الوسائل السلميه لكنها غير
مستعده للنظر في السيناريوهات التي لا
تحقق فيها تلك الاهداف كما قال المدوب
الروسي ان بلاده لم تعلن ان هدفها من
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وتدمير اوكرانيا
وان انهاء اوكرانيا للاعمال الادائيه
سيتيح لها فرصه ان تكون دوله طبيعيه وفق
تعبيره
وعلى وقع التصعيد واتهامات غربيه لها
بالتخطيط لدعم روسيا بالسلاح اعلنت
الخارجيه الصينيه انها طرحت وثيقه للحل
السياسي تتضمن الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار
واحترام سياده جميع الدول وحمايه المدنيين
واسرى الحرب
حديث الخارجيه الصينيه تبعه اعلان رئيس
الاوكراني نيته لقاء نظيره السنين فيما
نقلت صحيفه وولد الامريكيه عن مسؤولين ان
الرئيس الفرنسي
والمستشار الالماني اولى ابلغ الرئيس
الاوكراني انه بحاجه لبدء النظر بمحادثات
سلام مع موسكو وفي مقابل الاشارات
الدبلوماسيه تستمر حزم دعم العسكري الغربي
لكياب حيث قال رئيس الوزراء البولندي
ماتيوش مورفيتسكي ان بلاده سلمت اوكرانيا
4 دبابات من طراز ديبارد
ومع انهاء الحرب عامها الاول تحاول
اوكرانيا الحصول على اسلحه من الغرب
تمكنها من قلب المعادله على الارض في
التقرير التالي نتعرف على ابرز الاحتياجات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
ترتكز المطالب الاوكرانيه بشكل اساسي الى
الدفاعات الجويه والصواريخ بعيده المدى
والاسلحه المضاده للدبابات والمدرعات
بانواعها والطائرات المسيره لكن الامر
بحاجه الى منظومات متناسقه وتنوع في
المستويات لتناسب الصواريخ المعاديه فمثلا
لا يمكن استخدام صاروخ من منظومه باتريوت
تصل تكلفته الى ثلاثه ملايين دولار لاسقاط
الطائره المسيره لا تصل تكلفتها الى 20
الف دولار بينما تسقط الطائره المسيره
بصواريخ قصيره المدى او رشاشات ثقيله وهذا
امر تعاني منه اوكرانيا مع التفوق الروسي
في الاجواء الاوكرانيه
تحتاج القوات الاوكرانيه كذلك الى صواريخ
بعيده المدى كانت منظومتها الامريكيه قد
دخلت على المعادله فاثبتت كفاءه عاليه
وحيدت الامداد اللوجستيه للروس في المناطق
الجنوبيه والشرقيه تلك الصواريخ التي
استخدمت وصل مداها الى 80 كيلو مترا لكن
من هذه الصواريخ ما يصل مداه الى 160 او
300 كيلومتر ما يعني يدا طولا للقوات
الاوكرانيه في ضرب العمق الروسي وشبه
جزيره القمح اما في العمليات البريه فان
القوات الاوكرانيه بحاجه لاسلحه مضاده
للدبابات ومنها بشكل اساسي صواريخ جافل
وانلو وكذلك طائره بيرقدار المسيره
التركيه الصنع هذان السلاحان كان كلمه
السر في افشال الهجوم الروسي البري على
العاصمه في الاسابيع الاولى للحرب الحصول
عليهما الان يعني ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تتحضر لهجوم روسي اخر على العاصمه من
الشمال كما يعني فعاليه عاليه في مواجهه
التقدم البري من الجنوبيه الشرقيه في
المعارك البريه لابد من المدرعات الدفاعيه
والهجوميه الدبابات الثقيله والخفيفه
وناقله الجند الوعود الغربيه حتى الان
تتحدث عن اعداد قليله من هذه الدبابات ما
يجعل فعاليتها في المعارك محطه اختبار
معادله المسيرات تلك معادله اثبتت جدواها
بالنسبه للروس فضربوا بها البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه اكثر من مره خصوصا بالمسيرات
الايرانيه الصنع لذلك تطالب اوكرانيا
الغرب بمثل هذه المسيرات المتوفره لدى
معظم الدول الغربيه
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد كشفت الحرب عن سباق تسلح بين
الدول والتكتلات الولايات المتحده كانت قد
اعلنت عن تطوير اول قاذفه استراتيجيه من
الجيل السادس هي b21 لكن كيف تختلف اجيال
الطائرات عن بعضها البعض وما هي مميزات
الجيل السادس منها المزيد مع محمود الكن
اعلنت الولايات المتحده وعن قاذفه ب 21
الاولى من الجيل السادس من الطائرات لكن
لماذا تصنف بالجيل السادس وما هي المميزات
في هذا الجيل المختلفه عن سابقتها
الجيل الاول من الطائرات استخدم المحرك
النفاث
[موسيقى]
في الجيل الثاني ظهرت الاجنحه المرتده
للخلف والرادا
في الجيل الثالث الطائرات المخترقه لحاجز
الصوت
الرابع امتلك قدره عاليه على المناوره
وبصمه الرادريه منخفضه
اما الجيل الخامس فامتلك خاصيه الشبح
قبل ان نتجه للسادس دعونا نشرح ماذا نعني
بخاصيه الشبح وكيف تقاس
هكذا يبدو لنا حجم الطائره القاذفه من
طراز بي 52
مقارنه بطائره اف 16
لكن هاتين الطائرتين لا تبدوان كذلك
بالنسبه للرادار
للحصول على ميزه الشبح تصمم الطائرات بشكل
هندسي وباستخدام مواده في الهيكل تمنع
انعكاس اشعه الرادار
هذا ما يسمى بالمقطع الراداري العرضي هو
ما يراه الرادار من الطائره يقاس بالمتر
المربع
طائره b52 يقدر حجمها على الرادار بمئه
متر مربع في حين تمتلك طائره اف 16
مقطعا راداريا بمساحه اربعه امتار مربعه
اي ان بصمتها الرادريه منخفضه
لكن طائرات الشبح تمتلك اقل من ذلك بكثير
طائره اف 35 يقدر ما يراه الرادار بانه
بحجم كره الجولف اما بالنسبه للطائره
بواحد وعشرين فالمقطع العرضي للرادار تشير
التقديرات الى انه بحجم النحله او ربما
بحجم البعوضه هذا ما ستحتاج انظمه رادار
الدفاع الجوي لالتقاطه لكن ماذا يعني ذلك
بالنسبه لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
كلما صغر المقطع العربي للرادار كلما اصبح
تتبع الطائره اصعب وقلت المسافه التي يمكن
لرادار الدفاع الجوي اكتشاف الطائره منها
حتى يصبح الوضع متاخرا جدا لاعتراض
الطائره فحينها تكون الطائره اكتشفت
المنظومه واستهدفتها قبلها بكثير
كما ستساعد الطيارين بالتركيز على
العمليات القتاليه لان الذكاء الصناعي
سيتولى الكثير من المهام فيها
انضموا الينا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
لقاء مكه الباحث الاول في مركز الجزيره
للدراسات من وارسوا الدكتور عمر عاشور
استاذ الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه ومن
لندن كير جايز كبير محللي شؤون روسيا
وروسيا في معهد شتم هاوس اهلا بهم جميعا
نبدا بالدكتور لقاء مكي رغم اهميه هذا
البعد العسكري الذي تابعناه ولكن يبدو على
الصعيد الدولي التدافع السياسي
والدبلوماسي لا يقل اهميه حتى الان الغرب
تمكن من على الاقل عزل المؤيدين لروسيا
يعني جعلهم غير قادرين على التعبير عن
تاييدهم لروسيا ولذلك نجد ان الدول في
افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه عاده لديها
علاقات قويه مع روسيا لم تؤيد الغرب لكنها
ايضا لم تعيد روسيا وهذا شاهدناه في الامم
المتحده في الجلسه الاخيره لكن في النهايه
اعتقد ان ما تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل حول
الصينيه ربما ربما يكون هناك ما بعد هذا
والرفض الغربي المتوقع لها ان يكون هناك
رغبه دوليه في او زياده حده الاستقطاب
وجعل او شرعنه تاييد روسيا باعتبار ان ذلك
من موجبات السلام وعلى اعتبار ان الغرب لا
يريد السلام لان هذه الحرب اصبحت صفه
دوليه على الاقل فيما يتعلق بالغذاء
وتوريدات الغذاء وتاثير على الامن العالمي
اعتقد ان الدول مثل البرازيل وجنوب
افريقيا وهي الدول قريبه من الصين وروسيا
من دول العشرين ودول اخرى ايضا اقل منها
مثل الهند على سبيل المثال وبدول بريكس
تحديدا سيكون لديها الشجاعه اذا ما رفض
رفضت المبادره الصينيه وهذا متوقع ان يكون
لديها شجاعه لتاييد روسيا بشكل او باخر من
تاييد السلام او الضغط من اجل السلام وهذا
لصالح روسيا اي مفاوضات تجري اليوم الغرب
يعتبرها نوع من الهدوء المؤ او الملائم
لروسيا كي تستجمع قواتها وهذا غير مرفوض
بالنسبه للغرب ولي اوكرانيا لذلك اعتقد ان
هذه الدول ستضغط بهذا الاتجاه حده
الاستقطاب الدولي في هذه السنه في السنه
الجديده او الثانيه ستزداد وهذا سيكون
لصالح روسيا وتخفيفا عزله الدوليه هذا هذا
العام الثاني سيد كيد جالس في لندن العام
الثاني للحرب ما الذي يمكن ان ياتي به
مختلفا عن العام الاول
بدايه من المهم الاشاره ان هذه ليست السنه
الثانيه السنه الحربه بدات منذ عام 2014
عندما اطلقت روسيا هجومها على الشرقيه
اوكرانيا بعد ضم القرن بالتاكيد الامر
يعتمد وكما ذكر الضيف السابق على دعمي
للطرفين في الحرب وروسيا كانت ناجحه جدا
في جمع من بقيه اجزاء من العالم لان هذا
يتناقض لاننا نعتقد ان هناك معاناه في تلك
الاجزاء من العالم وخاصه من نقص الغذاء
وارتفاع اسعار الوقود وقد تنظر الى روسيا
بعين اللام لكن بطريقه ما روسيا استطاعت
ان تنجو من هذا الانتقاد
ومن هذا الانتقاد من بقيه اجزاء العالم
العام الثاني على السعيد العسكري الدكتور
عمر عاشور قد يشهد دخول اقوى للدبابات
واحتمال دخول طائرات الاب 16
ما الذي يمكن ان تغيره هذه المعطيات
يمكن ان تغير الكثير
المدرعات كما رايت في المرحله الثالثه من
الحرب اوكرانيا قامت بهجوم مضاد استعاده
بعض الاجزاء المحتله في في خرسان
وربما رايتم
كانت تستعمل مدرعات يعني
دروع مصنعه موجوده على سيارات مدنيه او
مركبه على سيارات مدنيه للتقدم بها من قله
الدروع عندهم
فوجود كما وصفها يعني بعض الجنود الذين
يتدربون على على
الدبابات الفهود الالمانيه يقولون تحولنا
من سيارات رديئه الى اتكلم عن 64 الى
سيارات مرسيدس يعني في فيما يخص مستوى
الدبابه
فستغير الكثير لكن الدبابات لا تقاتل
وحدها يعني الدبابات ولا بعدها الدباب
هائل تحتاج لصيانات لدينا تجربه سابقه في
المرحله الثانيه والثالثه حين تم استخدام
مدفعيه البنزين
بعضها بعد استخدام القوات الاوكرانيه تقدر
بها 300 قذيفه يوميا
لقطع غيار والطول الى ارسالها لبعض الدول
الاوروبيه القريبه لسعادتها فبالتالي خطوط
الامداد خطوط الصيانه
التدريب الاعلى اللوجستيك وتدريب ايضا على
استخدام هذه الدبابات سيكون حامل للغايه
لتحقيق ربما انتصار تشارك فيه تسهل فيه
المضارعات ونفس الشيء بالنسبه للطائرات
ولكن سيكون اعقد بكثير كذلك بالنسبه
للطائرات
فتره طويله للغايه
وربما اسهل لهم للاوكران الان اخذ من
الطائرات السوفيتيه انهم متعودون عليها
ولديهم خطوط الصيانه
والدعم لها على اهميه على اهميه هذا
الجانب العسكري معذره دكتور عاشور على
اهميه هذا الجانب العسكري اسهل السيد جائز
مره اخرى في لندن هل تتوقع ان ما سيحسم ما
سيحسم المعارك ربما ليس السلاح بقدر ما هو
التحركات الدبلوماسيه في العام الثاني
بالتاكيد ان روسيا ستكون منفتحه امام اي
جهد للوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار من اجل
انهاء القتال وايضا
دعم مكاسب روسيا لكن هذا لا يهم اوكرانيا
وليس في مصلحتها وبالتالي هي ستقام اي
محاوله للمفوضيه تريد
تحلل الازمه لان هذا الامر يساوي
لاستسلامي اوكرانيا لان اوكرانيا تحتاج ان
تحرر تلك الاراضي التي تم احتلالها والتي
رات احتلالا وغزوا روسيا تريد ان تحرر
مواطنيها وبالتالي تريد ان مساله تعزيز
اراضي المعركه هذا امر مهم لاوكرانيا
بالتالي اننا ربما سنرى ربما نوع من وقف
لاطلاق النار ودعوات المفاوضات لكن روسيا
لا ان توافق عليها لانها لا ما تزال لم
تخسر في الحرب وايضا اوكرانيا لن توافق
على هذه الدعوات لانها تريد الاستمرار في
تحديدا الدكتور لقاء مكي كاننا امام تسويه
مستحيله روسيا تريد تسويه تبقي لها ما
سيطرت عليه واوكرانيا تريد تسويه تخرج
روسيا من اراضيها كيف يمكن معالجه هذا
الاشكال في العام الثاني
الطرف الذي يجد طبعا انا استبعد اوكرانيا
لانه الحقيقه ان الغرب اذا توقف دعم
لاوكرانيه تنتهي اوكرانيا لذلك الغرب هو
ما زال يمسك بالمعادله الان الطرف الذي
يجد ان خسائر اكبر في حاله استمرار الحرب
سيدعم لذلك الان اذا دخلت الصين ودول اخرى
مهمه في العالم في هذه المعادله وزاد حد
الاستقطاب السياسي بين معسكرين داسيما
بريكس امام الناتو معسكر بريكس مهم جدا
ولم يفعل
لانه فيه روسيا والصين كقيادتين لم يفعل
حتى العلن على مستوى الاستقطاب السياسي
اذا ما دخل في مجال الضغط السياسي
والتلويح بدعم العسكري لا سيما من الصين
حين ذاك اعتقد ان التكاليف ستكون اكبر
طبعا الغرب ربما ينتظر الصين ان تتورط في
الحرب ليضربها لكن اذا ما دخل الدول
الاخرى مع الصين دول مهمه في الجنوب
لاسيما في البرازيل وجنوب افريقيا والهند
حين ذاك اعتقد ان الغرب سيجد ان التكاليف
ستكون اكبر الامر سيكون اكثر تعقيدا حينها
ربما سيعمل الى التفاوض لكن حتى الان هذا
بعيد الاحتمال نسبيا لكن هو ممكن يكون في
الاشهر المقبله عسكريا دكتور عمر عاشور
الولايات المتحده والغرب عموما لا يريد ان
يتورط في مواجهه مباشره مع موسكو ولكن اذا
استحال الحسم العسكري واستمرت موسكو في
موقفها هل هذا الاحتمال وارد دخول مباشر
واستدام مباشر غربي روسي
لا يحتاجون لذلك لا يحتاجون لذلك بشكل
مطلق واولا الرغبه في عدم مواجهه موسكو
كان متواجد يعني في 2014 حين اغرت القرم
كان ضغط حقيقي على كيف من قبل اداره
اوباما واداره ميركل بعدم الدخول في
مواجهه عسكريه ووعدهم ان يساعد كل شيء
بالدبلوماسيه والعقوبات الاقتصاديه ولم
تساعد القرم وهو مدافع
للمواجهه في صيف 2014 واستعادت في كثير من
البلدات هذا واحده او يعني بسلاح بسلاح
سوفيتي في صيف 2014 المدن التي نتكلم عنها
الان من ماريوب كل هذا تعيد في صفه 2014
وبعد ذلك في 2015 هذا واحد اثنين المنطقه
العسكريه الغربيه التي مفترض بها ان تواجه
النيتو
مفترض بها ان تهدد دول مثل بولندا ودول
صغرك استونيا منطقه العسكريه هذه الحادي
عشر في كل تقريبا دمر يعني اقترب من تدمير
التام في معارك سومي في وفي ومن الذي فعل
هذا هو الاوكران يعني النكته التي قالها
الرئيس
يعني
المواجهه بين النيتو وروسيا
روسيا خسرت حتى الان 180 الف
والسؤال ماذا خسر النيتو انيتو لم يصل بعد
المعركه
هذه حقيقه يعني هم لا يحتاجون للدخول حتى
الان ولكن لا يحتاجون هو الاستمرار في
الدعم والتدريب والتسليح
ولكن وهذا في حد ذاته يعني حتى الان لم
يحسم الام يعني اوكرانيا لم تنتصر
اوكرانيا لم تحر اراضيها
لم تنتصر دكتور عمر عاشور اوكرانيا لم
تنتصر وموسكو وهنا اسال السيد جائز موسكو
تعتقد بان ما يسعى اليه الغرب هو هزيمه
الاستراتيجيه لروسيا هذا التعبير هو
لمندوبها اليوم في الامم المتحده هل فعلا
الغرب يسعى لهزيمه استراتيجيه في العام
الثاني للحرب
هذا جزء من جدل كبير في الغرب هو الى اي
مدى يمكن دعم اوكرانيا اوكرانيا بالتاكيد
تستحق الدعم من اجل صدي روسيا لكن
الصد والردع الروسي النووي كان فاعلا في
استخدامك اداه تخويف الكثير من الدول
الغربيه في مساله استخدام السلاح النووي
لكن بالتاكيد فان الغرب
يتفادى هذا الامر ربما عفوا سيحققه عن
طريق منع روسيا من احتلال اوكرانيا روسيا
تعتقد لانها روسيا تعتقد ان من حقها ان
تعيد احيائي الامبراطوريه الروسيه في
الغرب هنالك اعتقاد ان هذا الامر غير
مقبول هذا هو التناقض البسيط بين الطرفه
بالتالي اي شيء يقوم به الغرب من الجائري
منع روسيا هو يمثلوا هزيمه لها شكرا جزيلا
لك السيد كيف جايز من لندن شكرا لك دكتور
عمر عاشور من وارسو وشكرا لك دكتور لقاء
مكه على حضورك معنا هنا في الاستوديو
امن من الحرب استطاعت القوات الروسيه
السيطره على مركز محافظه وحيد هو خرسون
لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تتمكنت من استعاده
المدينه مره اخرى تفاصيل معركه خرسون في
العرض التالي مع محمود الزئبق ضمن سلسله
المعارك الكبرى في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
اول مركز محافظه استطاعت القوات الروسيه
السيطره عليه خلال حربها على اوكرانيا حتى
الان
انطلقت الدبابات والمدرعات الروسيه من شبه
جزيره القرم في يوم الحرب الاول وعبر جسر
انطونوسكي على نهر دينيبرو ودخلت مدينه
خيرسون
[موسيقى]
بهجوم مضاد استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه
الجسرى في اليوم الثاني لكن قوات الروسيه
استطاعت محاصره المدينه مجددا الى ان سقطت
تحت سيطرتها في الثاني من اذار مارس
شهدت اطراف المقاطعه بعدها مناوشات كثيره
ومع اعتماد كلا الطرفين على القصف بعيد
المدى كان تزويد الولايات المتحده لكياب
لمنظومه صواريخ هايمرز منتصف العام الماضي
نقطه فاصله في المعركه
في نهايه اغسطس شنت القوات الاوكرانيه
هجوما مضادا كبيرا بالتزامن مع اعلان
موسكو عن استفتاء انتهى الى ضم خرسون
ومقاطعات اخرى الى الاتحاد الروسي تواصل
القصف العنيف بين الطرفين واستخدمت روسيا
في تكتيكاتها سلاحا جديدا هو الطائرات
المسيره الانتحاريه التي تقول كياب انها
ايرانيه السنه
على جانب الاخر كانت مدرعات بيبر
الالمانيه الحامله للجسور عنصرا مهما في
تعزيز قدره الجيش الاوكراني على عبور
الانهار والقنوات المائيه الكثيره في
المخاطعه خلال المعارك في التاسع من
نوفمبر اعلنت القوات الروسيه انسحابها وتم
تفجير الجسور بين ضفتين هاريليبروف عقب
ذلك
قال الكريم ان موسكو ما تزال تعتبر خرسون
ارض الروسيه رغم الانسحاب منها ورغم اعلان
موسكو سحب جميع القوات الا ان اوكرانيا
اعلنت سيطرتها على العديد من المركبات
الثقيله والذخائر التي خلفتها روسيا وقالت
ان كثيرا من الجنود الروس فشلوا في
المغادره واختباوا داخل المدينه بثياب
المدنيه
انعكاسات الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت عديده
الاقتصاد العالمي كان احد اكثر الجوانب
تاثرا الحديث عن سوق الطاقه وعن اسواق
الحبوب وغيرها من المواضيع التي شغلت بال
المراقبين والمحللين ينضم الينا من لندن
الخبير الاقتصادي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد اش هل
يمكن هل يمكن ان يكون العام الثاني للحرب
اسوا من حيث التكلفه الاقتصاديه
واضح كلما طال امد الحرب فان الامر يمثل
وضعا سيئا لاوكرانيا العالم الاقتصاد
العالمي بدا يتعلمه كيفيه التاقلم ربما
سنرى انخفاضا اقل في اجمالي الناتج المحلي
وربما اعاده تخصيص مثلا الاموال الغربيه
التي تم تخصيص الكثير منها لاغراض دفاعيه
قد يكون هذا ربما عملا مثبتا ربما نرى
نوعا من الركود لكن لنرى انخفاضا في ثلاثه
بالمئه اذا لم نرى ربما نوعا من النمو هل
يمكن ان نصل الى نقطه ربما تتحدث فيها بعض
الدول الاوروبيه او حتى الولايات المتحده
عن انهاك اقتصادي يستوجب العمل بقوه على
انهاء هذه الحرب
كلا اعتقد انه بعد عام توضح لنا ان الغرب
موحد بشكل كبير خلف اوكرانيا ليس هنالك اي
اشاره على الاطلاق لتقليل هذا الدعم
لاوكرانيا واعتقد ان لاحظناه اليوم بهذه
المبادره الصينيه التي حصلت اليوم ان
العالم موحد في كونه متشكك في هذه
المبادره الصينيه الجميع موحد انه لن انما
سيكون هنالك محادثات سلام عندما تريد
اوكرانيا ان تجري مثل هذه المحادثات يعني
اقصد اذا استمرت التكلفه الاقتصاديه بكل
هذا الضخ المالي لاوكرانيا هل يمكن ان
يخلق راي عام غربي يتذمر نوعا ما من
استمرار هذا الدعم
كما ذكرت الغرب موحد خلف اوكرانيا يعرفون
ان بوتين هو ديكتاتور شرير ارتكب جرائم
حربه قام بمهاجمه اوكرانيا هو يهاجم الغرب
علينا ان نوقفه اعتقد ان هذا موقف موحد من
قبل الغرب
لدينا مشكل في الغذاء ومشكل في الطاقه في
العام الاول للحرب هل تعتقد بانه يتكرز
ذلك اكثر في العام الثاني
حقيقه الامر على العكس من ذلك ما رايناه
ان اسعار الحبوب كانت اقل هي اقل اقل مما
عليه في عندما بدا الحرب وبالنسبه لاسعار
الطاقه كان هنالك طلب متزايد في اوروبا
واوروبا قد مرت خلاله فصل الشتاء هذا فوت
خسر حرب الطاقه التي
شنها هو خسر هذه هذا
العمل الضغط الذي كان موجودا لديه شكرا
جزيلا لك تموت يا الخبير الاقتصادي كنت
معنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
تستمر في تونس حمله الاعتقالات التي
بداتها السلطات هذا الشهر وشملت سياسيين
معارضين وشخصيات قضائيه واعلاميه ومدنيه
كان اخرها الناشط السياسي والقيادي بجبهه
الخلاص جوهر بن مبارك وفي ظل تواصل الصمت
الرسمي بشان طبيعه التهم والتفاصيل التي
تخص هذه الاعتقالات قال الرئيس قيس سعيد
ان الحقائق التي سيكشف عنها ستكون مدويه
ومزلزله وفق تعبيرها
[تصفيق]
تتوسع حمله التضامن مع المعتقلين في مبادئ
تعرف بقضيه التامر على امن الدوله
الداخليه والخارجي
الحزب الجمهوري الذي اعتقل رئيسه عصام
الشامي في القضيه نفسها اضافه الى قياديين
اخرين من جبهه الخلاص المعارضه يؤكد في
وقفه احتجاجيه ان استهداف المعرضين ياتي
لضرب التجربه الديمقراطيه والنيل من
الحقوق والحريات في مثل هذا الظرف الخانق
في ازمه
اولا اقتصاديه قبل كل شيء ولا اخال هذه
المداهمات وهذه الايقافات العشوائيه التي
تفتقر الى سنه قانوني والتي تفتقر الى
اخلاقيات لاخالها الا تغطيه على هذه
الاخفاقات
لم تختصر حمله الملاحقات القضائيه على
المعارضين فحسب بل طالت نشطاء ونقابيين
واعلاميين
بينهم رئيس النقابه الوطنيه للصحفيين الذي
وصف ما تقوم به السلطه بالمحرقه ثم محرقه
تعملها السلطه اليوم ضد كل الناس اللي
قاعده تعبر على اراها تمارس في حقها في
التظاهر مارس بحقها في التعبير ولا
تواجهها السلطه الا
القوه وبالابحاث وبالمحاكمات بهدف الترهيب
وفي ظل تواصل الصمت وزاره الداخليه
والنيابه العامه والقضاء يبقى الموقف
الرسمي مقتصرا على الرئيس قيس سعيد
الذي اتهم في اكثر من مناسبه خصومه
بالارهاب والتامر والخيانه وقال انه يعمل
على انقاذ الدوله التونسيه منهم
السراسير الى الامام ولا عوده الى الوراء
ابدا
ونعمل عن قاده دوله التونسيه
وتمكين التونسيين والتونسيات من حقهم في
الحياه الكريمه
ويرى متابعون ان موجه الاعتقالات وحاله
الاحتقان ستستمر في ظل استمرار الانسداد
الذي تعيشه البلاد على اكثر من مستوى
اثارت موجه الاعتقالات وعمليات الدعم التي
شهدتها تونس تمديدا واسعا وانتقادات
داخليه وخارجيه في حين يمضي سعيد قدما في
مشروعه الذي يقول انه سينقذ الدوله وينهي
حاله الخراب التي تعيشها
هذا القداع ستيفاندو جريك المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده الى الافراج
عن الصحفيين المعتقلين بشكل تعسفي واضافت
ردا على سؤال للجزيره بشان صحفي شبكه
الجزيره المعتقلين في مصر قال ان الامين
العام يدعو دائما الحكومات الى ضمان ان
يتمكن الصحفيون من ممارسه عملهم دون
مضايقه او احتجاز
ندعو دائما للافراج عن الصحفيين الذين قد
يكونون محتاجين بشكل تعسفي هذه مشكله
قائمه للاسف في جميع انحاء العالم وتزداد
سوءا والامين العام للامم المتحده يدعو
دائما الحكومات في جميع انحاء العالم الى
بدر قصاره جهدها للوفاء بمسؤولياتها لضمان
ان يتمكن الصحفيون من ممارسه عملهم دون
التعرض للمضايقه او الاحتجاز او ما هو
اسوا
انضموا الينا من تونس خالد البارودي
الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي ومن تونس
ايضا عبر الهاتف حاتم الرصاصي الخبير في
الحوكمه والرقابه نبدا بالسيد خالد
البارودي اهلا وسهلا بك
هذه الاعتقالات
الى متى ستستمر
مساء الخير
الحقيقه لا احد في تونس باستطاعته الحديث
عن مده معينه لنهايه هذا الكابوس الذي
تعيشه البلاد
لاحد يمكنه ان يجزم ماذا يريد السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه من وراء كل هذه الاعتقالات وكل
هذا التشدد في التعامل مع كل من يخالفه
الراي الى حد الان كثير من الاعتقالات
تحدث كل يوم كل يوم جديد ياتي بخبر جديد
في الاعتقالات ولكن لا خبر رسمي من الجهات
المسؤوله لا من الجهات القضائيه ولا من
الجهات الامنيه ولا من السيد رئيس جمهوريه
حتى رئيس جمهوريه يتحدث فقط عن بعض النعود
لكل من يخالفه الراي ويصبهم بالفساد
والمؤامرات وبالارهاب وكل ما
يعن له او يخطر على باله بالتالي لا احد
بامكانه القول ان ربما هذه المرحله قد
تنتهي في ربما الامر يعود الى كثير من
الاسباب منها محاوله التغطيه على الخيبات
المتتاليه التي مني بها سيد رئيس
الجمهوريه في كل ما ذهب اليه في مساره
الذي قال انه مسار للتصحيح سواء
بالاستفتاء او بالانتخابات الهزيله او بكل
الخطوات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه التي
تشهدها البلاد والصعوبات التي تحف بها
ايضا النقطه الثانيه ربما يحاول السيد
رئيس الجمهوريه ان يبعث اجواء من الخوف
والريبه والتشكيك في صفوف المعارضه
السياسيه ويقول انه قادر على لجمها وعلى
ان يحيط بها متى اراد ذلك ربما ايضا يريد
ان يبعث رسائل الى الخارج انه قادر اعلى
على شبك الامور وقادر على فرض الاستقرار
الذي يريده الغرب الاوروبي اذا اراد ان
يراهن على احد الاقوياء في المنطقه
وبالتالي هذه كلها تدعو الى
ان رئيس الجمهوريه لن يتوقف عن هذا المسار
سيحاول لملمه صفوف انصاره سيحاول تشتيت
انصار معارضيه وسيحاول فرض اليد القويه او
الجد الحديديه على كل من يعارضه وكل من لا
يذهب في النهج الذي يريد بالتالي ربما
يستمر هذا المسار مده طويله نعم في
المقابل سيد حاتم الرصايسي الرئيس قيس
سعيد يؤكد ويعيد لا عوده الى الوراء لا
عوده الى الوراء ولكن ماذا عن هذا الامام
الذي يذهب اليه الى اين يمكن ان يقوده
ويقود البلاد
سيدي الكريم مشكور على سؤالك هام جدا ولكن
حبينا نوضحه من خلال مصطلح متداول هناك
فرق شاسع وواسع بين مصطلح
الاعتقالات اللي هو مفهوم سياسي وبينما
لقاء يصير اليوم في تونس نحن
نتحدث عن ايقافات وليس اعتقالات
بالتالي الايقافات تنجم تكون
القانون وتفرضها الاجراءات القانونيه
وبالتالي
عمرها ما كانت السلطات الامنيه او
القضائيه بشتقوم بهذه
الايقافات بصفه عشوائيه او بصفه
ولكن هذه تتم بدراسه واتحت مسؤوليه مؤسسات
الدوله ولكن نقول وحلها الايقافات هذه
الاقامه ما كانتش مجرده او من الخيال
وبالتالي هنالك شبهات
[موسيقى]
القاضي الذي يطلق سراحهم هو شريك لهم ماذا
بقي للقضاء ماذا بقي للتحقيق ماذا بقي
للحوكمه
سيد الكريم لو تط
رقنا مفهوم الحوكمه رغم البرنامج يمكن
عنده فتره زمنيه ولكن يمكن مده
او مفهوم لمصطلح الحوكمه الحوكمه هي تعني
كيف نتصرف في موارد لتحقيق نتائج واهداف
وارباح ربما بامكانيات المتواجده لدينا
هذه هي مفهوم الحوكمه وبالتالي اذا كان
باش نطبقوا مفهوم الحوكمه على هذا الاجراء
او هذه الاليات بالتالي نقول نعم لك نسبه
من الكلام في الصح لكن السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه يقول بانهم
ليسوا بمجرمين لان من يقول كونه شخص مجرم
هو القضاء
ولكن بعد ذلك الرئيس قالها قالها مجرمون
وارهابيون على كل قبل قبل قليل يعني بعد
اذنك
اوردنا تصريحات لسفاندو جريك تتحدث عن
الصحفيين بشكل عام بما في ذلك صحفي
الجزيره ولكن الاستفاده ايضا اعرب فيما
يتعلق بتونس اعرب عن قلق المنظمه الدوليه
ازاءه التطورات الاخيره التي حدثت في تونس
لا سيما حمله الاعتقالات التي وصفها
بالتعسفيه بجريك دعا ردا على سؤال للجزيره
الى اجراء حوار بناء بين مختلف شرائح
المجتمع التونسي لدفع البلاد الى الامام
حسب تعبيره
ما زلنا نشعر بالقلق دائما نراه في تونس
لا سيما لاعتقالات التعسفيه فضلا عن تقلص
المساحه المتاحه للمجتمع المدني والصحفيين
ويشجع الحوار البناء بين مختلف شرائح
المجتمع التونسي لدفع البلاد الى الامام
سيد خالد البارودي عندما يقول لرئيس
الدوله بان ما سيكشف عنه من حقائق سيكون
مدويا ومزلزلا ما الذي نتوقعه
في الحقيقه المراقبون في تونس لم يعودوا
يتوقعون شيئا مما يصرح به رئيس الجمهوريه
سواء
اطلاق النعود على
المعارضه وعلى من يخالفه الراي قال كلاما
كثيرا يشبه هذا قال ان الحقائق ستاتي
مزلزله في حادثه في حادثه جرجيس وقال ان
هناك حقائق سيسعق لها كل من يسمعها وفي
الاخير سمعنا كلاما عاديا قاله جميع واتهم
الناس بانها تجمع الاموال
وعرفنا بعد ذلك انه من جمع المال هم بعض
السكان او بعض ابناء المهاجرين من المدينه
الذين ارسلوا بعض الاموال لمساعده اهاليهم
يعني سمعنا كلاما كثيرا من هذا القبيل ولم
يعد يفيد التونسيين كثيرا وربما هي اسلوب
ربما رئيس الجمهوريه في الخطاب يتحدث الى
انصاره دائما يحفزهم على المواصله في نعت
من يخالفوه الراي بانهم ارهابيون بانهم
فاسدون وبان هناك محاسبه ستاتيهم وهناك
للاسف الشديد هو يخاطب انصاره دائما ولا
او يدغدغ هذه المشاعر الشعبويه ويغذيها
ونرى هؤلاء يتحدثون عن كل المعارضه
ويصفونهم بصفات غريبه ويسبونهم ويشتمونهم
واصبحت حتى التسريبات في القضائيه
والامنيه تسرب او تخرج او تصدر عن هؤلاء
ولم يعد
التونسيون يقنعون او ربما يثقون في كل ما
يقوله للاسف الشديد
خالد البارودي بعد اذنك هذه الاجواء وهنا
اسهل سيد حاتم الرصاصي هذه الاجواء اعربت
عديد الاطراف
الامم المتحده فرنسا الاتحاد الاوروبي كل
هذه الاطراف اعربت عن قلقها ودعت تونس
والسلطه في تونس الى مراجعه السياسه
والسلطه في تونس تطمع في قرض من صندوق
النقد الدولي في هذه الاجواء من الذي يمكن
ان يقرض تونس في مناخ كهذا
الكريم للتوضيح صحيح كونه تونس تمر بازمه
ماليه واقتصاديه خانقه وكذلك ازمه
اجتماعيه وسياسيه هذا هذا لا يخفى على اي
حد سواء كان في تونس او خارج تونس ولكن
لا تحصل عليه من ناحيه الاقتصاديه
والماليه وصحيح كونه ثم حيوانات
قاعده تم بين تونس وصندوق النقد الدولي
ولكن هل الاعتقالات هذه ما عندهاش علاقه
بالحوار بين السلطات الرسميه
نقصد في وزاره الماليه
والاطراف المعنيه بالحوار والتشاور مع
صندوق النقد الدولي ولما ننساوش اللي
صندوق النقد الدولي طلاب العديد من الشروط
وبطبيعه الشروط هذه
هو في الواقع صندوق النقد الدولي ولكن هذه
هي مقترحات
مقترحات اللي تقدمت بها الجهات الرسميه
بتونس ولكن
صندوق النقد الدولي يحب اكثر ضمانات واكثر
شفافيه وتعامل خاصه مع جهه الجهات
الاجتماعيه
المنظمه الشغيله ولكن هذه العلاقه لا
بد باب الاعتقالات او الايقافات شكرا لكم
واضح شكرا لك سيد حاتم الرصاصي شكرا لك
سيد خالد البارودي
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث قتلت قوات
الاحتلال او بالاحرى توفي شاب فلسطيني
متاثرا بجروحا كان اصيب بها اول امس
الخميس برصاص قوات الاحتلال في مخيم
العروب شمالي مدينه الخليل بالضفه الغربيه
وقالت مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه ان الشاب محمد
جوابره البالغه من العمر 22 عاما استشهد
بعد اصابته بالرصاص الحي في الراس خلال
مواجهات وقعت في المخيم تمديدا بجرائم
الاحتلال واخرها مجزره نابلس
وكانت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه قد اعلنت
اصابه خمسه فلسطينيين بجروح جراء اعتداءات
لمستوطنين وبرصاص قوات الاحتلال في مناطق
متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه الليله الماضيه
واوضحت الوزاره ان مواطنين اثنين اصيب
بجروح وصفت بالخطيره جراء اعتداء مستوطنين
على المواطنين في قريه اسره جنوب شرقي
نابلية كما اصيب ثلاثه مواطنين اخرين
برصاص الاحتلال خلال مواجهات وقعت في قريه
النبي صالح شمال غربي مدينه رام الله
وقد اصيب فلسطينيون بحالات اختناق اثر
استخدام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الغاز
المسيله للدموع لقمع مظاهرات احتجاجيه في
مناطق عده بالضفه الغربيه فقد اشعل
فلسطينيون اطارات سيارات قرب مخيم العروب
للاجئين شماليه الخليل كما فرقت قوات
الاحتلال المظاهره قرب باب الزاويه المؤدي
الى البلده القديمه في الخليل ما ادى الى
اصابه فلسطينيين جاء ذلك احياء للذكره
التاسعه والعشرين بمجزره الحرم الابراهيمي
عام 94
وفي تطور الاخر قالت حركه السلام الان
الاسرائيليه المناهضه للاستيطان ان المجلس
الاعلى للتخطيط والبناء الاسرائيلي صدق
على بناء اكثر من سبعه الاف وحده
استيطانيه جديده في انحاء مختلفه بالضفه
الغربيه واشارت الحركه في بيان لها ان هذا
العدد يفوق عدد الوحدات الاستيطانيه التي
صدق عليها عام 2022 واضافت ان المخططات
الجديده تشمل تشريع خمسه
بؤر استيطانيه عشوائيه اقامها مستوطنون
دون ترخيص حكومي وتاتي هذه الخطوه
الاسرائيليه بعد اياما من اصدار مجلس
الامن الدولي بيانا دعمته الولايات
المتحده واعلن فيه عن بالغ القلق
والاستياء قرار اسرائيل التوسع في بناء
المستوطنات وقال بيان مجلس الامن ان
استمرار النشاط الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي
يعرض خيار حل الدولتين للخطر واعرب عن
معارضته الشديده لجميع التدابير احاديه
الجانب التي تعيق السلام بما في ذلك قيام
اسرائيل ببناء المستوطنات وتوسيعها
ومصادره اراضي الفلسطينيين واطفاء الشرعيه
على البؤر الاستيطانيه وهدم منازل
الفلسطينيين وتشريد المدنيين الفلسطينيين
وكانت تقارير صحفيه اسرائيليه تحدثت في
وقت سابق عن موافقه السلطه الفلسطينيه على
تاجيل التصويت في مجلس الامن على قرار
يدين الاستيطان بعد موافقه الطرفين
الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني على حل وسط امريكي
وفق التقارير الاسرائيليه فان اسرائيل
تعهدت بعدم اتخاذ اي قرارات استيانيه او
هدم منازل فلسطينيه خلال الاشهر المقبله
وكانت الحكومه الاسرائيليه اعلنت مطلع
فبراير شباط الجاري اطفاء الشرعيه على تسع
بؤر استيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه وهما
رفضته فلسطين ودول عده داخل مجلس الامن
الدوليين
الان الى اخبار الرياضه يسحبون فيها معاذ
بلحيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك محمد اهلا بكم الى جوله رياضيه
موجزه نستهل ومن اخر اخبار الكره
الافريقيه حيث تغلب المريخ السوداني على
ضيف الشباب بلوزداد الجزائري بهدف دون
مقابل في الجوله الثالثه لحساب المجموعه
الرابعه لمسابقه دوري ابطال افريقيا
للمره الثالثه كان شباب بلوزداد يبحث عن
هدف التقدم في مباراته امام المريخ
السوداني لكن الحارس محمد المصطفى تصدى
لتسديده ليونيل وامبا امامنا هنا كره
مسدده وحصل المهاجم البرازيلي باولو
ديسوزا على ركله جزاء حولها بنفسه الى هدف
افتتاح النتيجه لمصلحه الفريق السوداني
عند الدقيقه الثانيه والثلاثين
ثاني حاول الفريق المضيف مضاعفه النتيجه
لكن الجازولي سدد بجانب القائم
ثم سدد زميله باولو ديسوزا خارج اطار
المرمى
لا والله ده قوله ده باولو وفي الوقت بدل
الضائع تصدى حارس شباب بلوزداد قندوز لهذه
المحاوله
لتنتهي المباراه بفوز هام للرفقاء حمزه
داود
وضمن المجموعه الاولى تغلب الوداد المغرب
على ضيف بترو اتلتيكو دون مقابل هدف
الوداد جاء من ركله جزاء عبر يحيى جبران
في الدقيقه الرابعه والثلاثين بهذا الفوز
حقق الوداد انتصاره الاول رافعا ثلاث نقاط
من مباراتين
في المجموعه الثانيه لدوري ابطال افريقيا
ايضا الهلال السوداني تغلب على الكاميروني
بهدفين لهدف وسوف تتح النتيجه لمصلحه
كونتوسبور عند الدقيقه الثالثه والاربعين
وفي الدقيقه الثانيه والخمسين ادرك
للبوء التعادلات للهلال السوداني
ذات اللاعب ليحرجه ثانيا له ولفريق فحقق
الهلال فوزه الثاني رافعا رصيده الى ست
نقاط
[موسيقى]
كوره بالشبكه
افريقيا كذلك تعادل المنتخب التونسي مع
نظير دون اهداف ضمن مباريات الجوله
الثالثه لكاس امم افريقيا تحت 20 عاما
والمقامه حاليا في مصر رغم الفرص المتاحه
للاعبي المنتخبين فان المباراه انتهت
بتعادل سلبي رفع المنتخب التونسي رصيده
لنقطه في المركز الثالث ورفع
منتخبتين في المركز الثاني لحساب هذه
المجموعه
ام سامي شوشان
[موسيقى]
اوروبيا ومنذ قليل تغلب على بروسيا
مقابل في الاسبوع الثاني والعشرين من
الدوري الالماني لكره القدم الكوري
الجنوبي لجاي سونج افتتح تسجيل لماينس في
الدقيقه الخامسه
والعشرين بعد الاستراحه بحوالي اربع دقائق
الدنماركي ماركوس
ضعف النتيجه لاصحاب الارض
قبل ان يعزز الفرنسي لودوفيك اجورك التقدم
بهدف ثالث في الدقيقه الثانيه والسبعين
ستم نيلسون فيبر في الوقت محتسبا بديلا
الضائع الرباعيه ماينس في هذه المباراه
اوروبيه ايضا الجمعه سحبت قرعه دوري 16
للدوري الاوروبي لكره القدم في مدينه
نيونس سويسريه واسفرت عن المواجهات
التاليه
[موسيقى]
نقطه النهايه اذا لهذه الجوله الرياضيه
الموجزه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
بهذا نصل الى نهايه جوله الحصاد تصبحون
على خير بقيه المواعيد الاخباريه يسحبكم
فيها عثمان الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]